one of the things I love in your book is
you're writing about you know the early
days of Rolling Stone and everyone
always wants to know how where did the
name come from and uh you know sure
enough I get from the book that Mick
thinks you got the name Rolling Stone
from the Rolling Stones but in fact Bob
Dylan Like a Rolling Stone that's where
the name came from right it wasn't Mick
it well it was primarily because of
Bob's song because that was right in
fact which later on over the years
became in Rolling Stone's number one
rock song of all times but
um
it was I gave credit essentially in the
first issue to Bob but I also mentioned
the stones as them having a name too so
kind of shared and then once one of the
best experiences of my life was I was
inducting the stones into the VH1 or the
MTV Hall of Fame and in the introduction
I thank them for the use of the name and
then Mick came on says oh you're so
lucky we gave you your name because
otherwise you would have been called
Herman's Hermits monthly big lie
so that a week later Bob is doing MTV
Unplugged in New York and I went up and
said hello to him there he says I saw
you last week on on the television you
gave the credit for the magazine to the
stones and you know perfectly well it
was my name you got the name for me so I
thought well first of all I quivocated
kind of like oh I didn't mean I mean
what I really meant well you know all
this groveling and [ __ ] and then I just
thought I am talk about being flattered
I mean these guys are kind of equivalent
over the credit for it wow not
unequipping over the credit but they
were kind of pissed at you like Mick was
pissed at you and everyone felt ripped
off and they somehow you owed them
something do you wish in retrospect you
didn't call the magazine Rolling Stone
and just have some original name where
you didn't have to deal with all these
guys I couldn't think of an original
name remember it's the theory of the
Grateful Dead in the Jefferson Starship
and a movie grape and all that stuff so
a weird thing of names like you know
what the electric apple or the electric
typewriter or nothing quite work I mean
who can you imagine if you called the
electric apple and you were trying to
interview me about the electric Apple
today so
and
it turned out that Rolling Stone was a
great choice I mean because in it and it
was kind of odd at first but it you you
make it mean what you when you do
whatever it is that's what the meaning
becomes and what a great name for a rock
and roll
newspaper and it really stood out and it
was really unique and uh and then this
worked out fantastic and Mick I mean
neither of them were really ever angry
about it you know